Much like bathroom-humor at the dinner table,
hemorrhoids can be a taboo subject.
However, the truth is that everyone has them.
Their job is to protect your anal sphincter
muscles (the ones that open and close your
anus) and to help keep your anus closed when
you have moments of increased abdominal pressure,
like when you’re coughing.
They become a problem when they become inflamed.
Once this happens, they’re known as piles.
Of course, popular culture has led to “hemorrhoids”
and “piles” being interchangeable in common
vernacular.
In any event, by the age of 50, about half
of the population will have dealt with these
inflamed itchy protrusions at one point or
another.
Because most people with piles get curious
about why their backside is itching, let’s
take a closer look at what they are, what
causes them to become inflamed, and how you
can prevent that from happening.
Your anus is controlled by one of the many
sphincter muscles within the body.
Sphincters are muscles that form like a doughnut
around the many openings within the body,
like the entrance and exit of your stomach.
Those would be the lower esophageal sphincter
and pylori sphincter respectively.
When sphincters relax, they allow the entrance
or release of liquids and solids.
Normally sphincters are constricted which
keeps those liquids and solids from leaving
their respective positions within the body.
No one likes the acid from your stomach coming
back up and making your chest feel like it’s
on fire!
As mentioned before, your anal sphincter is
cushioned by hemorrhoids.
Hemorrhoids themselves are made up of what
are known as modified squamous epithelium.
These highly vascular cushions reside along
the anal canal in three main areas- the left,
right and back of the canal.
They are made up of elastic connective tissue
and smooth muscles.
Many of them do not contain muscular walls
like arteries and veins do.
Because of this, they are technically known
as sinusoids (a small blood vessel like a
capillary) and can swell up due to blood not
being able to leave.
When you’re relaxed, they provide about
15-20% of the pressure keeping your anal canal
closed.
When you have an increase in abdominal pressure,
like when sneezing, the blood going back to
your heart through your inferior vena cava
is reduced.
This causes these vascular cushions to swell
up with blood pushing on your sphincter, and
thus, help prevent the infamous anal-leakage.
It’s also thought that hemorrhoids are responsible
for helping us determine the exact content
of what’s coming out, like gas versus a
solid bowel movement.
When your hemorrhoids begin to swell up chronically,
they begin to cause problems.
This is when they become known as piles.
Once they are piles, they can cause symptoms
like hard lumps that can be painful and itchy,
the feeling like you still have to go to the
bathroom after you’ve already gone, and
mucous discharge or bright red blood while
defecating.
Anything that causes an increase in your abdominal
pressure can cause your hemorrhoids to become
chronically inflamed.
Thus, there are risk factors for piles- things
like being pregnant, chronic constipation,
lifting heavy weights, straining when passing
stool, being obese, and increasing age.
Some studies have even suggested the tendency
to develop piles is inherited.
You have two types of piles, internal and
external.
A line known as the dentate line is what differentiates
them.
Located below the dentate line is external
piles.
These are covered by a type of skin called
Anoderm that contain nerve fibers, specifically
fibers connected to the pudendal nerve.
The cause of the itchy pain is revealed!
Internal hemorrhoids are broken down in to
4 classifications.
1st degree protrude only into the anal canal.
2nd degree protrude outside the canal but
go back in spontaneously.
3rd degree require you to push them back in
manually, and 4th degree don’t go back in
to your canal no matter what you do.
The treatment for your piles depends on severity.
If only minor, your doctor may choose to simply
treat the symptoms, administering things like
corticosteroids to reduce inflammation, laxatives
if constipated, pain medication and anti-itch
creams, as well as advising you to attempt
not to strain while on the toilet, and to
use simple pads to help with irritation.
If your pile is more cumbersome, your doctor
can choose to remove or reduce the pile.
They can do this in a variety of ways.
Banding involves placing an elastic band around
the base, cutting off blood-flow to the pile.
After a few days, it will die and simply fall
off.
They can inject medications into the pile
causing it to shrink, known as sclerotherapy.
Surgery is also an option.
They can remove the pile (hemorrhoidectomy),
or staple shut the blood-flow to the pile
itself.
In the end (pun intended), contrary to popular
belief, everyone has hemorrhoids.
Scratch your bums with pride knowing that
about 50% of you will have yours inflame by
the time you’re 50.
Let’s just hope it’s only a minor inflammation,
because no one wants a Doctor cutting anything
off down there!